It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
And today- Huh?
We're also looking at cats right before this.
Right before this.
But now we're looking at you, Ruffians!
Thank you for joining us for our one hundred and fifty-fifth.
Yes!
Fifty-fifth episode!
What's that?
I told you, Moco-chan, it's getting harder to count, okay?
It's not, okay.
You just have to be prepared.
A hundred and fifty-fifth is not that hard.
Get over it.
BAU BAU!
Wow, for Ruffians that are joining us for the first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
AKA FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
So, please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's do a BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
The smiles on your face are very obvious!
What did you just say?
The smiles on your face...
Wow, we're still gonna do our best here, okay?
Ah, nothing is wrong with the left paw.
No.
You just only know the right paw.
On a happy note.
Happy note.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Well, you know, we're just about here at the weekend!
Yay!
Exciting things.
One weekend is right before us.
Nothing's in our way, right, Moco-chan?
There's one thing.
One thing?
Let's get rid of it then.
What is it?
A Pero sighting?
Another Pero sighting.
Mobius, there's been a Pero sighting!
Are you worried about Pero safety?
Abyss, this is all about your safety, okay?
Huh?
I know you care, but I think your heart is in the wrong place.
Don't go back to bed, okay?
Rip the band-aid off, you wanna know?
Let's take a look.
Where was Pero seen, Moco-chan?
De-den!
A terrifying sight.
Oh my gosh, Ruffians, be careful!
You might break your games!
You don't crush your controllers!
You gotta get them out of there, okay?
But, uh, he's playing a racing game.
A racing game?
Is this perhaps because Pero can't drive a car?
Maybe it comes from a longing to be behind the wheel.
Or, you know, maybe he just had too much fun playing F-Zero 99 together with the Ruffians, you know, like he did the one time.
Maybe he's just trying to, you know, live back the memories again.
Playing a driving game.
He can play?
He played with you before, Ruffians.
But Ruffians, you know, either way, you have to be careful.
Make sure this doesn't happen to you when you visit the washroom at night, okay?
No, also don't, when it's a dark room, you shouldn't be that close to the monitor.
That too.
It's not safe.
Not good for your eyes.
We don't need to worry about Pero, you know?
He can have bad eyesight.
But you, you need good eyesight, okay?
Let him play!
Don't bother him!
It's a bother!
I'll be careful.
Tap tap tap.
Mr. Pero!
You know, I wouldn't want to interrupt your game, but I think you should take a few steps back from the screen.
It's not for me!
It's for your sake, okay?
Is bothering Pero safe?
You have to do it very carefully because you don't know the outcome.
You have to be ready, okay?
Ready for the worst case outcome.
You already have bad eyesight.
That means you got a prize.
You get to wear cute glasses.
But you also need to protect them more, okay?
BAU BAU!
The games are yours, okay?
Ruffians gotta protect them, okay?
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
I heard that it's our turn to get
Pampered!
Because we just released a new voice pack!
To be pampered!
To be pampered
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
In a very special situation.
Yes, it is a situation voice that we have recorded.
Very immersive.
Yes!
You know, and we put our full hearts in it.
Yeah!
It's like a full, you know, drama scene.
You know?
Very immersive, like we said.
And there's an English version and a Japanese version.
And, you know, I'm... I... You can't pound for me when I'm not feeling well and my tummy hurts and I have a headache and...
That was good, you really liked it.
I got pampered!
You got that!
Oh my!
It's a little embarrassing.
But it's only digital, so.
Who's pampering who?
This time we're getting pampered by you, Ruffians!
Got it!
I know.
But we always do our best, so I'd love it if you could check it out there, Ruffians!
You know, I hear that digital merchandise is popular right now.
So maybe if you're like, yeah!
Digital merchandise, yeah!
You can go check it out too.
And if you're still kinda like, what exactly is this?
Please go take a listen!
I think you'll be surprised.
We were listening to a bunch of the samples, you know, because we saw that, you know, I think some of our senpai, some of our kouhai did Japanese ones.
Yeah!
Oh, it's so cute!
It's so good!
I was listening to Gigi sample a Japanese one of her voice plays.
It was so cute!
Yeah!
It was so...
Please check it out, especially, you know, maybe other EN members are like, oh, I haven't heard them speak Japanese.
If you like this voice pack, we have one for you as well!
All digital, so.
Please check it out on the camera, please!
Is Jiji Japanese cute?
Yes!
Very cute!
Does Jiji also have a Japanese one as well?
I don't think so.
I would've listened to that one, too.
Yeah, so.
Please check them out!
BAU BAU!
Now is the sweetest time to get a very sweet voice pack.
I really like the little things that you prepared for me.
I thought it was funny.
BAU BAU!
Wow.
It's been a big week!
With hololive English we've had a very big, big special project going on!
hololive English Enigmatic Recollection Chapter 2!
A Minecraft Roleplaying Project!
And slowly but surely it's coming to an end!
Very exciting, dramatic, and you know...
Kingdom of Lobesto.
Maybe there's some Ruffians that are like, I wasn't able to catch the previous stage.
Do we have a summary, Moco-chan?
We did this last time.
And Fuwawa said she's gonna try to summarize everything that's happened.
Let's do it together, okay Ruffians?
And said, are you sure you think you know everything that has happened?
Definitely don't.
Wow, the story goes that there is a kingdom called Lobesto.
This is also right after chapter 1, just in case, just in case.
Okay, she's gonna try her best.
It's not accurate probably.
And that is the king, the king, what's his name again?
King Lobesto?
King Lobesto!
And we have to get the memories.
And then, then, in the end, you know, we get rid of the stains.
That's the day.
And then, you know, yes, stains, goodbye.
But the king, the king is a stain.
He's the king of stains.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
We go back in time!
Yes!
And we meet a little mouse named Fia!
No, Fia's a cat!
No she's a mouse, Moco-chan!
Fia's a cat!
And, uh, she's lost some of her memories and we're in each of the bustle!
We travel to each of the bustle!
We're trying to figure out what is the outside.
How can we find the outside and can we turn back time?
Can we fix it?
And then there's...
Queen Yathania!
And there's a prophecy that Ancient Labesso will be ruined.
By the Ruination.
So you have to stop it and also get these memories back.
We only have 7 days?
7 days!
Yeah!
7 days.
And so we get memories of Fia's back and we kind of learn these memories.
And there's the Outlander.
But we learned that there's the Outlander.
Yes!
And the Outlander is a great, great hero.
Mysterious hero.
But kind of
And then we find out that the Outlander is the Outsider.
And it's going to, or becomes the Outsider.
It's going to start a prophecy and it's bad.
But Infarnia maybe loves the Outlander?
We don't care because we're the Shining Stars.
And so we beat the Outlander Outsider.
We have to find the Escapist?
What?
I don't know.
We are making it up.
But we show, we show that we're strong!
But in the meantime, what has been going on?
There has been a lot of drama, and of relationships, and of betrayal.
And some of us might just be cooking.
What else?
Some of us might just be... Therapy!
Yeah?
What else has been going on?
Uh... Therapy.
Boniton.
Potatoes!
You never know what's going to happen once you look into child care.
You never know what's going to happen.
So please check it out.
There is still a few days until Anorekko Chapter 2 comes to a big finale.
So we hope that you'll join us at hololive English on the remaining journey.
Adventure to adventure!
To adventure!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO!
I don't think anyone expected this.
Do you think my summary was good?
Out of 10!
Rate the summary!
Yeah.
Out of 10.
That's just like you did it!
FUWAMOCO!
11 out of 10!
I thought you got a 10!
Is there any escapist?
I think there was a mention of an escapist.
The outsider, the outlander, the escapist.
Right!
I'm not just adding something new.
No escapist.
The Watcher?
I don't know who that is!
It was the Watcher!
Oh, okay.
I don't know.
Both sound accurate.
You don't know about the escapist?
Okay.
BAU BAU!
Just the other day too, it was a birthday!
It was Harusaki Nozoko's birthday!
There was something special that happened!
She debuted!
A brand new debut on the whole ANA channel!
Did you check it out?
Did you hear about it?
Maybe not.
But you know, a very special event on her birthday.
But you know, this kicks off a brand new, new show, new in Japan show that Nodoka, that she will be hosting called Hiruhoron.
Hiruhoron!
It's once a week, and this way through Shiroholo you can understand what is going on in hololive, the big events, maybe the things you might have missed, and just a way to be able to cheer on everybody in hololive!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
FUWAMOCO!
We'll continue doing our best with FUWAMOCO Morning too!
BAU BAU!
You have to check it out!
Go check it out!
Versus!
No versus!
No rivalry!
Just support, you know?
Support, you know?
Being able to spread the news and exciting things happening at hololive.
It's just bonus, bonus, bonus, plus, plus, plus.
No minus.
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO We had some happy news!
Happy things happened to us!
It's funny how happy things happen to you, huh?
The other day we got an exciting notification!
A certain Poruru-oneechan sent us a gift!
Thank you, Poruru-oneechan!
Thank you!
Look, I'm so fluffy and fuzzy now!
Look at the fluffy cow!
I don't know what an avatar decoration is, but now I have one because Poruru-oneechan gave me one!
Yeah, and I'm gonna use it my entire life from now on!
I did not get a photo of mine because I was too excited.
I didn't notice that I got one for a little while.
I was like, oh, that's good for you, Moco-chan.
But poor little onee-chan, she's a smart older sister and understands, you know.
You have to be fair, otherwise.
But apparently she sent so many GIFs that she got locked out of Discord.
Discord got a little grumpy there, huh?
Yeah, Kanata-senpai too.
She thought she was the only one to get a gift.
No, Kanata-senpai, we also got one too, huh?
You're not special.
Yeah, no discord avatar.
I don't get discord.
It shows you that this is what you're getting.
Yeah, I have a discord avatar.
It has not changed once.
Moco-chan, not changed once.
Yup.
And this shall be the same.
It will stay forever and ever because it's a special gift from Poruru-oneechan.
Very special gift.
Thank you, Poruru-oneechan!
Present!
FUWAMOCO, you do the same!
You don't really change things up either!
What?
If it's good, then why not type it?
It's good, it's good, alright?
It's good, it's good.
Good things are good.
Perfect.
Yeah.
FUWAMOCO, we match too!
Yay!
We're matching!
BAU BAU!
And other happy news!
FUWAMOCO!
Ruffians, you know how we like Twitter, right?
Well, it just so happens that I think you like Twitter too because... No!
We have over 500,000 followers on Twitter!
Ruffians like Twitter!
Thank you, Abyss!
You know, I really like Twitter.
It's fun to be silly on Twitter and also see what kind of silly things you're getting up to, Ruffians, too.
Apparently, I think we have a lot of tweets.
Apparently?
I don't really think so.
Although we do find, you know, the sillier the tweets get... The more free... freedom we feel, right?
Nothing silly!
But thank you so much, Ruffians!
We really, really like being able to, you know, have lots of fun on Twitter together, so... Lots of silly Twitter drafts.
Lots of silly drafts, you know, so... We hope to continue to have lots of fun together on Twitter, so... Thank you so much, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
More silly and needy tweets!
More silly tweets, that's for sure!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
I'll try to keep the neediness to the voice back on.
BAU BAU!
We also figured out something very important, basically.
There's not a normal, you know, FUWAMOCO Morning type of stuff, but
We have a FUWAMOCO life hack for you.
You know, I'm still a Ruffian.
Sometimes, kind of like, all the interesting things happening on my phone, you know, Twitter, YouTube.
Like me, FUWAMOCO is streaming.
De-den!
If you use a black and white mode, black and white filter, then your phone dies.
It dies.
It's dead.
It's boring.
You can't use it.
It's good for nothing.
Use a black and white filter.
You know, isn't it exciting for the TBR?
They're fun animals, that's for sure!
They're fun animals, they are in black and white mode.
These animals are black and white mode, you know.
FUWAMOCO, we're, you know, pink and blue.
And maybe, you know, it kind of loses some of the fun.
You can't tell what color everything is anymore!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
It seems like, you know, the clock strikes this time.
Oh no!
Black and white.
I think you know it perfectly!
And then that way, Ruffians, you can get an even better rest.
I have a way of sleep before I need to look at the phone.
So just a little life hack from my routine.
A life hack from FUWAMOCO to you, FUWAMOCO routine!
Check it out.
BAU BAU!
It makes really loud.
I just don't need it right now.
BAU BAU!
Let's take a look at our Doggie of the Day today!
I wanna see the Doggie of the Day!
We have De-den!
Today's Doggie of the Day is Nico!
BAU BAU!
Nico!
Somebody's having fun.
Those teeth, too!
The teeth are so shiny!
Really white teeth.
We can tell Riko really loves to play.
I can imagine Riko going like... Whipping his head side to side, side to side.
But you're not gonna let it go!
Because Riko will probably just hand it back to you, right?
BAU BAU!
Very cute!
Moco-chan, how do we go BAU BAU?
Probably like... BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
Well you know, Riko looks like such a fun and loving puppy buddy.
Always playing together, you know.
Maybe even when you're like, right now is not the time to play.
The fun does not stop.
Never stop.
But you know, no matter how many years pass together,
I think you know he's always happy to be your puppy.
Let's play together!
Don't forget the playtime, okay?
Don't forget the playtime.
More consequences.
Yeah.
Bye!
Thank you!
Wow, let's take a look, Ruffians!
You go out, take a walk, and let's see what you went out on today.
I went on a walk.
We have... De-den!
What's this?
A secret garden?
Oh, it's an arch!
An arch made of branches of vines.
Tree arch.
It's so cool.
I'm wondering, you know, maybe somebody made it, or it didn't happen.
I don't know, maybe nature just took its course.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Photoshoot time!
Yes!
Well hopefully you'll have those pretty dragonflies and the flowers to join you in the full adventure.
BAU BAU!
Why is it such a cool walk?
Yeah, that's what I love about walks.
You never know what you're gonna find.
Do you pass into another world?
See ya!
BAU BAU!
And next we have our Question of the Day!
Today's Question of the Day is... De-den!
Hello FUWAMOCO!
How to stay energized through the day and start it on the right paw.
Sometimes it's hard to stay positive or productive when you're tired.
So I wonder if you have any special methods.
Coffee salad never works.
It's okay!
We totally get this!
Yes!
You know, sometimes we lose speed when we get really sleepy.
Yeah, you should go... And then...
It's not really working anymore, huh?
Yeah, and we're the kind of puppies where if we drink tea or coffee, it doesn't do anything to us.
No.
Yeah, so... It's good, you know.
When we're slowing down like that, we take a nap.
A nap.
Yeah.
Because you know, once you're kind of refreshed, you can go even faster.
Yeah, and you're like, okay, I'm good to go.
Right?
You can get better results.
But sometimes a nap isn't so restful.
Yeah, that's the downside.
Yeah.
But you know, I understand how you might just want to power through it.
Yeah!
We can take that to your place.
Right?
It doesn't work well though.
That's the danger.
You have to make sure you get up.
Yeah, that's where having a sister is helpful, right Moco-chan?
You know, if not a nap, just a good walk too.
Yes, but you have to get the power through that, huh?
Yeah, that's right.
But you know you never know what you're gonna see on a walk, so... If you go to sleep, you're just gonna see the pillows.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
We hope that you know you're able to stay positive.
Sleep is very important to stay positive.
And routine.
Routine, yeah.
Together we're routine, okay Ruffians?
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Thank you so much for all your submissions!
We're always waiting for more Doggie of the Day Perro Sightings!
Questions and rewards too, so... Are you getting therapy right now, Moco-chan?
So please send it to us with the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Thank you Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
We have another stream coming up very shortly here.
We have De-den!
And record!
And record day 7!
There's not too many days left now.
What will happen in the Kingdom of the Bustle?
You know, I heard there's gonna be a party happening.
How will the party go?
I didn't hear about a party.
Well, maybe Mococo, maybe Mococo will become the richest in all of Ubisoft.
We'll have to see.
You never know what happens in Ubisoft.
You never know.
BAU BAU!
And look at our schedule here.
Wow, Saturday is the big finale.
Day 8 of Enrico.
And once we've done that, you know, it's kinda lonely.
Gotta say goodbye to the best of everybody there.
But not quite!
Because it's Nala's birthday!
And we're gonna be playing Among Us together with her.
And some other whole EN members too.
We will see.
It's been such a long time since we played Among Us!
You remember it!
When we last played Among Us!
It was a long time ago.
It was over a year ago.
Over a year ago.
Our first time playing Among Us with Raora too!
Right!
I'm so excited!
We hope that you'll join us for Raora's birthday!
FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
But the Ruffians joining us today in the archives!
Your FUWAMOCO word is... BAU BAU LIFE HACK!
BAU BAU!
So our FUWAMOCO Morning is now... Yes.
Life hacks.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Thank you all fans for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
TASK!
BAU BAU!
JASKIM!
TAKOYUMI!
BAU BAU!
Dandelion.
Tohiho.
Tsuchi.
YZA.
Kuroneko.
Hiyoyoi.
Abou.
Ha!
BAU BAU!
MC!
Mr. Shadow Ant!
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This is today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!